listen can i just tell you something a
lot of people say that maybe we're at an
unfair advantage here that's actually
not true it's a lot harder to dance
blind okay like full-on blind like i
have no idea what cody is doing the
beauty of ballroom is that i can
actually um look he can look like he's
leading but guess who's leading i'm
leading you know and i could help the
celebrity get back on time to music
let's say if they're off time so
musicality takes into into consideration
here this is why most celebrities you
never see them just on their own doing
solos because it's not easy so we just
did a side by side jazz number that cody
learned in less than 48 hours okay mind
you with the emotional rollercoaster of
like are we dancing are we not dancing
what are we doing oh cool oh no oh no
kova kovat everywhere and so like um
i thought he did he's a 10 in my book
well that's all i'm gonna say
how are you guys feeling i mean what's
going to happen do you know what's going
to happen this coming week
yeah we're we're letting all the experts
decide on like timing and sort of stuff
like that but
we will be rehearsing via zoom a little
bit more this week and then we will have
time before we're in the ballroom next
week
to dance together
so it's still logistical kind of like if
we get cleared right
yeah we got to get cleared and then
we'll we'll be on we'll be in the
ballroom next week so i'm i'm so excited
for disney week i'm a massive disney fan
there's a mickey mouse on my
arm right here so
a tattoo so i'm just so excited for
disney week next week
and what would you say to brittany right
now after you know i mean you are a
super fan so what would you be saying to
brittany now
what kind of inspiration is she
oh my god you know britney has just been
like is i think when i think of britney
spears i think of like being resilient
you know she's had paparazzi following
her she's had the media trying to knock
her down she's had you know tons of
situations where
people people think she's gonna crack or
fail and she's gotten up every time and
kept pumping and evolved and so when i
think of brittany i think of resiliency
and that's exactly what i was trying to
tap into this evening
um was resiliency you did it
thanks
yeah sure anytime booboo
now when it came to the eliminations
what were your emotions when you weren't
in that first group i had a stroke
well they say in don't they say in no
particular order hold on let me tell you
something i was never never in my all 24
seasons i've done the show was i ever
alone
with that heartbeat in my that music you
know that like music that gives you
anxiety normally you're like all clammy
with your partner like sweating and
nervous and like oh my god oh my god
i'll be good now i got no one to talk to
but just my thumbs texting cody
that was a different experience that i
never want to experience again i'm doing
it by myself like a little
nerve-wracking uh i was just trying to
like breathe and smile you know
the smile
did you see my face i was like this
who were you guys impressed with tonight
okay so
well
to be honest here's the thing
is that we did have the luxury of doing
that in our home this evening so i tried
just a little bit a monitor and not
watch anybody because i didn't want to
make it i didn't want it to make me
nervous so i didn't watch that many of
the routines because i was at home so
but all i heard was scores like seven
eight seven yeah i don't wanna hear the
numbers eight seven i was like oh we're
totally gonna get sevens like because
that's the goal like you wanna slowly
climb up but we're still at the best
number ever sixes
all right well i'm looking forward to
seeing you both next week so thank you
thank you so much thank you have a good
one